ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das wort
schneeflocken gesellschaft das habe ich
aus der redaktion gehört ich hätte da so
auch gar nicht gewählt was mir einfach
am herzen liegt und ich habe das ja eben
schon angedeutet mehr liebe möchte der
muss liebe sehen wer frieden möchte der
sollte mit der sollte frieden verkündet
ein bisschen sich das auch bei meinem
thema ich bin ja comedian ich hier
bringen menschen zum lachen und ich
finde dass ist das oder eines der
wichtigsten dinge gerade in diesen
zeiten die nicht einfach sind für viele
menschen ist es sicherlich noch
schwieriger als für uns fünf die hier
sitzen und da tut humor einfach gut ich
finde es aber fast schon nicht nur
schade sondern ist schon schrecklich
dass man mittlerweile sitzt beim humor
bei jedem zweiten wort oderwitz
aufpassen muss ob das nicht irgendein in
seiner formulierung vielleicht dass der
uni das kann man so nicht sagen also ich
habe ja gerade eben habe ich ja bewusst
gesagt ja also ich bei ihnen der lassen
daher eindeutig habe ich jetzt wirklich
da hab ich jetzt gehört irgendwo sagte
jemanden liebe guest ihnen ja dann denkt
er sieht sich vom fernseher und
so dass er dann lieber lieber gast liebe
gastritis also du musst nein aber der
kann ja mittlerweile ältere menschen
können ja teilweise auch gar nicht mehr
folgen so jetzt kann man daraus gags
machen oder auch humor machen das mache
ich ja und trotzdem habe ich dann auf
einmal ein publikum leute sagen ja das
finde ich jetzt aber nicht gut also ein
witz über die annalena baerbock das ist
doch unsere zukunft ich sage ja aber wir
sie am ende ist es doch eine comedy show
und ich finde das ist ganz wichtig dass
wir noch differenzieren können was ist
denn eigentlich witzig gemeint und was
ist nicht ja aber wenn man da und es
gibt immer irgendwo wo man sagen kann
wird es über einen dicken ist auch nicht
schön oder über einen der ein blinder
ist ist wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer
aber wenn wir jetzt schon anfangen sagen
oh eingewachsene fußnägel da darf man
keine witze darüber machen da muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen nein dann traut man
sich ja irgendwann auch keine inhalte
mehr zu machen und ich finde das ganz
ganz schade weil ich glaube ganz viele
menschen die da draußen sind die lechzen
förmlich nach humor die wollen einfach
mal lachen auch mal über ein thema was
vielleicht ein bisschen ernster ist weil
ich finde man kann mit humor auch ernste
themen in eine gewisse leichtigkeit
überführen oder auflösen und ich finde
das tut uns einfach dass er mit resi
weil man keine witze machen darf
ich würde das ich würde jetzt nicht
irgendwie sagen ich nehme jetzt das oder
das thema da darf man keine witze machen
ich glaube natürlich je härter in
anführungsstriche das thema ist desto
besser sollte der witz sein ja aber es
ist auch immer die frage der situation
ist derjenige der den witz gerade hört
es gibt manche die sind einer
beschwingten leichten situation und die
lachen herzlich über den witz und ein
anderer hat gerade schwermut und er sagt
auch gut das ist jetzt aber eigentlich
mein thema und so aber ich kann ja jetzt
auch nicht dann darf ich wirklich nichts
mehr sagen und ich finde es immer
zigeunerschnitzel ist ein gutes beispiel
viele wir haben 40 jahre lang haben sie
alle [ __ ] schnitzel gegessen also
schnitzel mit paprika soße kein mensch
hat sich gedanken darüber gemacht ob das
in irgendeiner form vielleicht
verwerflich sein könnte sondern wir
wussten alle es ist halt im schnitt mit
paprika soße und heute sieht man da und
sagt ich nehme schnitzel ohne festen
wohnsitz war das jetzt ok haben sie das
auf der karte pasta schnitzel ungarische
art so und da muss man aber ehrlich sagt
ja kann man ja darüber diskutieren aber
in dieser vehemenz in der das
mittlerweile passiert hat und das finde
ich schon ich finde das schade einfach
das nimmt uns so viel leichtigkeit ja
dann ja früher war alles besser ich habe
das natürlich sei das sagen sie nicht
lieber nicht alles passiert dass ich
leute aber
ich gebe zu ich hab es das erste mal
gesehen ich sehe das jetzt aber auch als
bildungslücke und schreit interview von
ihnen damals und das finde ich passt
sehr gut zum thema um wieder einmal
reinzuschauen
ist eine isländische mannschaft die
meisten spiele spielt in england der
zweiten division sind da auch nicht
stammspieler wir müssten doch eigentlich
von der position her die wir haben von
den besetzungen die wir hier haben die
mannschaft klar beherrschen das haben
wir nicht so müssen wir den
gemeinschaften klar beherrschen wie
seine spieler die ist löhne sind
tabellenführer das weißt du was sind sie
dabei entweder nicht richtig er also
alle müssen ihren gegner auswärts klar
beherrschen und in welcher welt leben
wir denn alle ich hab gedacht ich mache
ich schon wenn die gemeinschaft
vergleiche ich habe doch die mannschaft
hinter und auch delling die natürlich
von delling ist natürlich schon dass du
dir sagst du mich einfach mal sagen ich
kann diesen scheißdreck nicht mehr hören
ich muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich da
stelle ich mich vor die mannschaft aber
wenn ihr müsst auch mal von ihrem hohen
ross runterkommen was ihr euch immer
alle einbilden was wir alles was mit
fußball gegen deutschland spielen müssen
ihr habt doch früher da könnte was die
früher für ein scheiß gespielt haben da
kurz davor gar nicht hingegangen da
stand fußball gespielt ich kann jetzt
nicht verstehen warum die schärfe
reinkommt wahrscheinlich nicht jedoch
ein müssen wir uns dann alles gefallen
ich habe da kann ich jetzt noch nicht
locker bequem hier auf dem stuhl das
treibt weizenbier getrunken
das ist ja sehr sehr zäh denn ich habe
es ja schon wirklich oft gesehen ich war
ja in vielen sendungen bei waldemar
hartmann und ja es stimmt ich bin auf
tour mit mut zur lücke und natürlich
habe ich auch viele fußballer die ich
parodieren weil die ich habe immer schon
mal wieder versucht auch dass ich wollte
ich bin ich mal gucken vielleicht dass
du im original und ich mache den rudi
völler auf tournee gehen hier hat man
jetzt wieder etwas einfallen lassen sie
dann wäre das gefragt wie beim dfb ist
gehört er gedacht wird er müsste von
seinem honorar ein bisschen runter damit
[Gelächter]
zum thema humor als sehr viel wahrheit
drin also wir haben zu ddr zeiten sehr
viele witze gehabt die wir hatten waren
auch so du wusstest du mit witzen über
über über das wasser helfen so zu sagen
und man merkt eigentlich immer dann mit
dem volk soll gerade viele witze
kursieren über die regierenden zum
beispiel das dann wieder irgendwas am
schwelen ist und irgendwas nicht hinhaut
und wenn keine witze gemacht werden das
ist dann wie wenn ein kinderzimmer ruhig
ist da musste gucken gehen da ich ja
irgendwas im bus wobei die hitze sehr
gut waren weil ich sicher verschlüsselt
werden mussten sonst ja aber da war dort
muss ich viel luft verschafft jaja
tragen und auch jetzt muss man wieder
mit humus ein dienst schreibe ich auch
meine bücher ich schreibe die auch mit
humor weil das erträgt das ja gar nicht
mehr den ganzen katastrophen kann ich
alle nicht mehr hören das leben geht
weiter der klimawandel ist schlimm dass
wird probleme geben aber die welt geht
nicht unter ja gegen ein schweizer
freunde zu mir gesagt du ich war jetzt
drei tage inkl
ich habe festgestellt ihre deutschen
jammert jetzt schon darüber dass hier
ständig lammert
[Gelächter]